uh
let's talk about what is going on you're
no longer on
the fighter and the kids what happened
all right i know everyone everyone wants
to know the unknown but let's just talk
about the gnome first
yes all right you have your podcast the
cutting weight shout out to cutting
weight yeah
podcast the weight cutters and babies
you know i mean with me and i got justin
elliott
um and again let's just talk about the
the gnome first before we get into that
yes
um they said i you know they said
they come on monday mornings like yo
malik b he's fired
and started laughing right and and come
in and
i would never do that you know that's
poor character on their parts
right i mean just and again you watched
the show right have you ever yeah i i
saw
i saw uh i probably catch like one you
know i went to high school with
chappelle
so anything he does i try to support um
but uh i caught the beginning of that
episode
yeah and again that's all you should
have watched but uh the the
then he tried to come back and talk
about my work ethic now i want to talk
about
you know the things that you know what
you see
let's just see let's just talk about
what you see in front of you if you
watch the fighter in the kids
right let's talk about people characters
now
i kept a professional the whole time
right you never would see me
you know talk over anyone you never see
me like uh
interrupt anyone i'll have a negative
attitude right just like i'll come on
your podcast you're very positive
every time right you know but then you
got these guys that turn their back
talk over you you know don't acknowledge
you so i'm just sitting there sometimes
i'm like
you know and i don't you know when you
people have poor character i don't feed
off that
right you know i mean i like positive
things like you would like positive
things around yeah so again
i just just to go off that and then you
you can always act like
i'm happy they brought brian calling
back i'm happy about it but i've been
with brian the whole time well i i do
remember him talking about you on the
podcast before
he was off of it bro brian i've been
around brian brian knows i don't talk
behind anyone's back
there's no knowledge of me because he
knows my character right and
i've been around like even when he was
in the situation he he was before he had
to left
like once he left the show for the
allegations
i always spoke holly o'brien because
when he was around me i was like bro he
always had
he was a man of his word you know he did
what he said he was going to do
and i loved that his character was
impeccable and then people were asking
me about like why
you know what he do i was like i don't
know that's not that's not my affair i
don't speak on it
right i'm just telling you how i dealt
with brian and brian catlin can attest
you can go ask him like what kind of
character malik is he don't talk behind
people back right he don't do that he's
a man of his word and if he doesn't
just speaks on his character but again
he i'm pretty sure he won't because he's
a great guy
i can't i can't say the same thing for
those guys over there you know what i
mean because again what you just
like i said just look at the known you
know look at people's character i'm
always professional so when you talk
about
you know get on there and start oh he
got fired and started laughing
that's unprofessional of course you know
i mean like yo come on that just shows
and then just
like that's a negative i mean if they
want to be negative like that let them
be negative you know and i don't feed
off negativity
i'm not a palace i'm not a negative dude
but if you you know clap back and stuff
like that like you know what i mean
you you put like a smut on my rep i
don't like that and i gotta clear these
negative vibes like yo
now they'd be lying and all that no oh
you go to my podcast a lot of people are
like yo malik is so different over here
what's it over there you know i mean
because i was like bro you go to an
environment
and it's just so toxic you know i mean
just like yo you know
you know even if off camera i'm always
professional right
and then you just carry that and you
just hurt your own podcast so that's
i'm gonna speak on that but you know i
mean i don't i don't really vibe with
that kind of you know
people you know because then we are we
are in the comedy world we got to see
these guys and i always built
i'm a guy that like i'm authentic like
what you see is what you get i'm a
stand-up dude i have principles i have
valuables
i don't talk behind anyone back i don't
do that even if they did that i'm like
man you will not see
any text message of me talking behind
anyone back right
i mean even when they did i'm like man i
don't got that you know that's none of
my affair
i don't like gossip i don't talk behind
people back so
that's that's that's the whole
environment so i just want to just paint
get that negative picture out
of like yo mallet got fire and they
started laughing like kev if i come over
here
and i was like yo you know so uh kev was
like um
kev you'll never do that but kev cheated
on his wife right
right but but but they're doing he's
gonna no it's gonna be a great
they're gonna work it out like that you
like [ __ ] what
right you know what i mean like that's
that's what i think of you you know and
i was like man okay cool but then i
gotta get
clear all that around my name because
you know i mean i don't like that i
don't want any negativity around my name
and again i'm that's all i gotta say
about that yeah i mean
i think um if you
read the comments which i'm sure you've
read a lot of people would say that you
put up with a lot of